happy birthday Shaquille a day in
advance I'm not gonna give you any
Marilyn Monroe breathy singing because I
don't want to lose our audience you know
I don't want to sing happy birthday to
you and like a low breathy Marilyn
Monroe style because I don't want people
to turn the TV off like
breathy you know come on you don't never
get back on the air that way how are you
Shaquille I'm doing fabulous lovely to
talk to you and we're good we're really
good we're you know I made rich loses
his plane ticket on the way home and I
have to be here tomorrow it's okay
I can be around I can get sitting I got
it tell me this we were texting last
night when you saw Kobe Bryant up there
accepting an Oscar went through your
mind family immediately I'll tell you I
thought it was interesting I thought
that it humbled Kobe to see him up there
out of his element to see him accepting
the award like that I actually thought
it showed a different side of him though
we don't see that often yeah it was
funny look very nice I think this
watching all three of his daughters it
was actually the first time I was I
didn't even know he was up on tuition
uh-huh in a water park yeah best
animated short for goodbye basketball
Shaquille let's talk about your son
chérif obviously do you committed to
Arizona and I was committed to UCLA Sean
Miller obviously the school is still
standing by him any regrets for him at
all not staying with Arizona is 18 and
you know with me sort of like deja vu
panning you know when I was coming up my
father said you know a young man you can
analyze something that you make your own
decision my 105
let's do that he didn't see what about
fall and what the dance became a whack
so he called me said dad what should I
ask what you want to go because as you
consider your choice so this la you want
to stay in their home and you want to
play for Coach Alfred you want the play
goes with his partner Jules and I said
oh well that's what you get you gotta
let the people Arizona know your armor
man and you got the business to
correctly each other correctly and I
wish everybody well I hope the rumors
about you can show that this election
abilities a good guy anybody go out in
the candle controversy so hopefully
things turn up what kind of player is
Charisse play that he's really good
again with the day job apparently I've
never told it's always wrong I like
where he's at right is not he's not
you can't teach him more stuff and he's
very he's a very humble kid this is very
well I'm actually blessed to have a
child no problem whatsoever he loves to
work and I don't have to push him when
he was younger and we were living in
Miami I thought he's gonna be 686 nice
always like a key back she's brought it
up
he's gonna be working on ok Maga man
just working out a lot for guys y'all
know he's gonna be getting a lot of
knowledge but if he he continues to do
things for a pretty good one I know what
a hands-on dad you are with him
Shaquille O'Neal what is it like for you
and I and I remember your relationship
with your dad so but what is it like for
you to have the attention off of you and
on your child
it's actually about 18 years old and
sometimes I want to play after you know
I like to be hard on time I have to you
know you know sometimes I'm a brings a
tear to my heart
he does and I'm playing so beautifully
and Mike remember at times of high
school McArthur my dad he had the same
look on his face but I'm it's just you
know wonderful to watch and I have to
teach him early I said listen
your name's O'Neill it's going to be a
lot of pressure I tell him I said you
know pressure and shake no dad that's uh
pressure is we don't know where your
next meal is coming from
best vocal is if you paid the players
don't really have pressure so I'll just
go out and have fun and make sure you
never have to back em tomorrow
that's how always play it like there's
no such thing as pressure if you go down
and our land homeless wrong you see all
those beautiful people they're not
having no place to stay that's question
you know our pressure is all athletes
that's one thing I appreciate with you
shakila's that you always have the right
perspective that you don't take it for
granted in that you don't forget that
there's a lot of other people out there
that would be so lucky to be near even
one of your oversized shoes you know so
that makes a big difference that said
did you see Chuck on Saturday Night Live
this weekend those parables are worst
performers over it was turn you can't do
it you can't do a second person but it
didn't work
putting the Chia on his head he had the
LeBron up there yeah I think we have to
put a call in to SNL right away and get
you back on there let me ask you about
this have you ever considered throwing
any food items of anybody in the NBA of
course although did you ever throw
anything well yes and another difference
is if you didn't up on the twelve people
and it got out one of the twelve guys
know something one of the twelve guys
have to take consequences you next day
of practice no you should call honest
every joke
we should do a lot of crazy stuff what
about on the TNT desk would you ever
want to throw perhaps an egg foo yung
over a Chuck shut em up I want to just
hit juggler Cheryl do I always help you
always tell people get up and punch
Chuck and walk off just know that one of
my stocks here that [ __ ] don't be ready
to retire retire I mean you didn't shoot
him
at one time and they did didn't you yeah
but that was more like you know it's
like you know prospective because no you
hit me with the balls I bet like a WWF
by the way I could see you guys doing a
little WWF skit are you hearing me still
all right I thought I may have lost you
there I was gonna burst into tears on
live television
Shaquille looking ahead again this is TV
I don't get dressed I don't do hair and
makeup for radio Shaquille oh yeah this
is big-time babe babe this is national
well you know some say I left the
building years ago but that's neither
here nor there
I once kicked a wall in the Staples
Center because I was so mad at and
another reporter who tried to steal a
story and then I got in trouble but
that's just another story
nobody could steal your stories you're
the only one that got in depth well you
know what I appreciate you saying that
because uh ancient history but you know
what we had a good time together
let me ask you this could you played
with the balls right now
would you feel about a dad calling the
shots from the sidelines well me my dad
had to have that final argument to let
him know I was a man and actually when
we had the final art he said you know
what you're a man I'm Bradley I'm
waiting for you to do that all your life
he said lucky she said no the reason why
I want to you know still be hands-on
because I don't want about it so you
know take advantage said I'm a man I got
it don't worry about it so let you know
we had one little final argument we hug
we had dinner and he says you're mad you
don't know if you ever DP out here so my
father's tried it just seems to me she
killed that if Lonzo ball said to his
dad I've got a GM I've got it I've got
an owner I've got coach's dad this is my
time and total of our ball just to sit
down
wouldn't it just make basketball so much
better for everybody involved you know I
really you know I hear levar you know I
don't really hear much some Alonso but
you know on the flip side of that you
can't tell people to raise the children
no to me
yeah I do you know so I don't I think he
should do as you say all I know is my
son is a man and I'm a treated like a
man a little bit goes on better
decisions and I will never but if you're
not going to see me now I'm gonna see me
being his agent you know gonna see me
doing this marker and hey he got his own
thing you know I would just be a proud
dad and sit back if he needs my place
he's not he knows that I have a plethora
of useful information when it comes to
this this lifestyle so but I'm not gonna
be do this do that do that and it's
actually out that way how are you gonna
spend your birthday give us a little
peek working working players only that's
right I like the place the other work
chocolate vanilla what are we gonna do
[Music]
justice or no vanilla cake I get it I
get it you got it you can't have your
birthday without a cake come on you know
the expression let them eat cake what's
your dessert of choice you know what I
realized that I had a blessed career
listened to my parents are staying out
of trouble I always tell my kids every
day is my birthday no long as I can wake
up happy and everybody's happy
every day is my birthday I'm good we're
wishing you a very very happy birthday
and thanks for being my television
security blanket because I don't seem to
be able to do a show without having you
callin and you always do okay Joe I love
you Sookie oh oh thanks a lot
that's Shaquille O'Neal here on the Rich
Eisen show